merci beaucoup d'être avec nous pendant
cette première demi-heure élu de
Vaucluse membre du groupe républicain
vice-président de la commission des
affaires sociales on va parler santé
avec vous et hôpital dans quelques
instants mais d'abord évidemment la
réforme des retraites qui a donc été
annoncée hier par Elisabeth borne 64 ans
en progressivement en 2030 pour
atteindre cet agent 2030 l'accélération
de la réforme Touraine qui augmente la
durée de cotisation mais sans dépasser
les 43 annuités à préciser Elizabeth
borne est-ce que c'est une réforme que
vous voterez
dans le texte actuel je connais pas
complètement je vous rappelle simplement
qu'il y a depuis cinq années à peu près
régulièrement tous les ans la majorité
sénatoriale présente des modifications
importantes sur la retraite et le texte
qui a été présenté dont on parle
beaucoup dans la presse actuellement est
un texte qui ressemble comme deux
gouttes d'eau au texte que nous avons
déjà voté et qui avait d'ailleurs je
dois le dire à l'époque était rejeté par
le gouvernement bien donc le
gouvernement qui n'a pas voulu votre
texte encore il y a quelques mois en
arrière maintenant l'applique et le met
et le propose au vote du parlementaire
donc je dois dire donc si le texte
ressemble comme celui que à celui que
nous avons voté il y a aucune raison de
ne pas le voter je pense d'ailleurs que
les mesures essentielles la durée de
l'allongement de des cotisations et
l'âge de 64 ans ce sont des propositions
qu'a fait être né Paul Savary qui a
faite la commission d'affaires sociales
du Sénat depuis 5 ans et que donc nous
sommes il y a aucune raison qu'on évoque
pas
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez faire que
la discussion que nous pourrions avoir
les amendements que nous pourrions
présenter sur sur l'handicap sur les la
pénibilité etc il faut regarder tout ça
de près ce sont des sujets importants
que pour lequel évidemment
la presse n'en parle pas beaucoup pour
l'instant mais on en parlera dans le cas
des discussions qui auront lieu au moi
ce que je voudrais revenir c'est sur le
terme qu'utilise régulièrement la presse
en disant la droite les LR sont
satisfaits on ne peut pas être satisfait
d'un allongement à 64 ans et déjà un
logement des cotisations c'est une
obligation pour que les retraités futurs
et des ressources suffisantes pour vivre
convenablement c'est une obligation
parce que l'évolution de la ville
l'évolution de la science l'évolution de
la santé permet de aux gens de vieillir
beaucoup plus longtemps quand j'exé la
médecine la moyenne d'âge entre 76
la date de décès pardon était aux
alentours de 70 entre 70 et 75 ans
maintenant c'est entre 80 et 83 ans pour
les hommes et 85 ans pour les femmes
donc il y a un allongement de la vie en
bonne santé en plus qui doit permettre
par ailleurs à ces gens-là qui prendront
leur retraite de le faire et en bonne
santé et avec des ressources suffisantes
des propositions qui sont faites qu'on
ne fait pas de Dia de coeur mais qui
sont nécessaires et cette réforme là
présentait hier elle garantit
l'équilibre du système en 2030 c'est
l'objectif affiché bien sûr pour
l'instant oui c'est une réforme que nous
avions proposée René Paul Savary a fait
un travail considérable sur le sujet il
nous a bien montré et ça a été confirmé
par le corps que c'est cette réforme là
permettrait jusqu'en 2030 au moins après
ça sera un petit peu plus compliqué
probablement d'avoir et un nombre de
retraités importants et un nombre de
retraités avec des ressources
suffisantes il y a pas effectivement
vous l'avez dit il y a pas que le report
de l'âge légal de départ ou
l'augmentation du nombre d'annuités il y
a aussi des mesures sur les carrières
longues des mesures sur la pénibilité
des mesures sur le la retraite minimum
est-ce que l'équilibre entre la réforme
financière que vous souhaitez et une
réforme de justice sociale a été trouvée
en tout cas on le recherche il est
recherché en permanence et on ne peut
pas
ni à la majorité sénatoriale ni au
gouvernement reprochait de ne pas faire
l'effort nécessaire de cette recherche
qui est évidemment souhaitable et de cet
équilibre qui est évidemment souhaitable
donc là de ce côté-là on ne peut pas
dire que c'est suffisant mais on peut
dire que la recherche a été faite et on
peut donc saluer cette recherche sur les
1200 euros qui s'appliqueront donc c'est
une 1200 euros c'est la retraite minimum
qui sera donc à tous les retraités c'est
ce qui est Elisabeth borne c'est une
bonne chose pour vous parce qu'il y a
quand même une question de finance
publique aussi pour vous ça a été balayé
hier par Bruno Le Maire et que ça sera
compensé notamment par une autre branche
de la sécurité sociale a eu deux
discours hier matin il disait cette
c'est 1200 euros etc ça a coûté un peu
plus d'un milliard au budget de des
caisses de retraite et c'est énorme et
le soir il dit faut le faire bon il y a
eu évidemment entre temps des des AR qui
ont été faits et qui vont dans ce sens
là
c'est aussi une demande de Monsieur
Ciotti
je crois que en fait
là aussi c'est une demande nécessaire le
problème moi ce qui m'inquiète toujours
c'est les ressources et le financement
de ces de ces propositions
un milliard a trouvé d'ici le mois de
septembre en plus des dépenses qui sont
déjà faites au niveau des retraites
c'est énorme la France en dehors des
complémentaires chaque année dépense à
peu près 300 milliards pour les
retraites ces retraites elles sont
évidemment vous le savez aussi bien que
moi financé par les cotisations
essentiellement par les cotisations et
donc si on augmente les dépenses il faut
d'un côté pour ne pas avoir évidemment
des un endettement beaucoup trop
important au niveau des retraites
augmenter les ressources alors on peut
augmenter les ressources en augmentant
les cotisations mais on peut aussi
augmenter le ressources en augmentant le
travail en faisant en sorte que
l'activité économique
ce fait de la musique
cette réforme elle va rapporter quasi 18
milliards un 17,7 milliards que le
déficit n’étant que d'un peu plus de 13
milliards il reste un peu plus de 4
milliards pour des réformes de justice
pour vous c'est pas le bon calcul
c'est plus de de relancer l'activité
économique et de faire en sorte qu'on
ait un nombre de cotisants qui
augmentent régulièrement ça c'est ça
c'est la vraie
solutions soit une pension de réversion
pour les enfants handicapés alors
évidemment on comprend l'enjeu humain
mais est-ce que là aussi il y a des
questions financières qui se posent elle
se poseront obligatoirement mais bon là
moi je suis concerné directement j'ai
adopté il y a quelques années en arrière
une enfant handicapée il est évident que
lorsque les parents décèdent
disparaissent ce qui est la nature des
choses les enfants handicapés qui
deviennent adultes handicapés se
retrouvent généralement en difficulté
financière énorme alors qui est une
réversion pour les handicaps
c'est plus que nécessaire c'est aussi
quelque chose d'humain bien évidemment
et les ressources financières devront se
retrouver encore une fois de plus en
augmentant le nombre de cotisants et pas
les cotisations sur le véhicule
législatif utilisé puisque ce sera un
projet de loi de finance rectificative
et donc pas un texte Haddock alors
Isabelle bordi comprendre que ça pose
problème à certains dans l'opposition ça
vous pose problème ou
si on a au Sénat moins qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale de ce que j'ai entendu tout au
moins par rapport au nombre
d'amendements qui pourraient être
déposés par certains types d'opposition
qui
insoumise qui annonce des milliers
d'amendements des centaines de milliers
d'amendements oui c'est à dire que la
France insoumise qui régulièrement se
plaint de ne pas pouvoir discuter
travailler etc là empêche vraiment la
discussion et le travail bon ça c'est un
autre sujet mais cela dit au Sénat le
texte lui sera discuté et comme c'est
nous les sénateur de la majorité
présidentielle de Gérard Larcher qui
avons en somme mis en place ce texte
qu'on le veuille ou non et là et le
gouvernement pourra dire ce qu'il veut
sur le sujet c'est quand même le Sénat
qui a fait le boulot à l'époque il y a
4-5 ans en arrière comme c'est nous qui
avons mis ce texte en place et nous qui
connaissons bien le sujet en particulier
sa varie et donc on va faire le
nécessaire pour que ça se passe le mieux
possible que les discussions puissent
avoir lieu et que le gouvernement puisse
comprendre que nos demandes les demandes
sont faites pas la majorité et par le
Sénat en général sont des demandes
logiques les syndicats se sont réunis
hier soir on l'avait sur les images ils
annoncent déjà une journée de
mobilisation le 19 janvier est-ce que
vous craignez ils veulent mettre la
France à la race est-ce qu'ils disent
est-ce que vous craignez que le
gouvernement recule face à la pression
de la rue
j'ai pas le sentiment pour l'instant de
ce qu'a dit Madame borne que le
gouvernement a l'intention de reculer ça
dépendra évidemment de de la violence
parce que là c'est s'agira plus de
manifestation mais de violence
toujours la violence dans les
manifestations je dois dire j'en
discutais hier encore que
[Musique]
comment dire ça sans personne
le texte que nous allons voir c'est
quand même un texte de d'une société qui
fête quand même qui est une société
riche qu'on le veuille ou non
moi je travaille actuellement au Conseil
de l'Europe je vois ce qui se passe en
Europe de l'Est en particulier que ce
soit en Ukraine que son Arménie que ce
soit dans tous ces pays en Moldavie que
ce soit au Kosovo ou ailleurs
ils ne discute pas pour l'instant de
l'âge de la retraite ils en sont loin
malheureusement pour eux et je pense que
c'est bien pour nous de discuter de ça
et de faire le nécessaire pour que
l'ensemble des retraités puissent avoir
une retraite convenable mais ce serait
bien aussi que de temps en temps on
regarde ailleurs et qu'on se dise il
faut aussi travailler pour la paix en
Europe on va parler santé puisque
l'actualité du Sénat est marquée entre
autres aujourd'hui par un débat sur
notre système de santé on va en parler
avec notre journaliste parlementaire 6
jours là
[Musique]
bonjour Steve bonjour Hélène bonjour à
la maison bonjour et Sylvain débat sur
la crise du système de santé a donc lieu
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle il sera sur
une question du Plan Santé détaillé
vendredi par Emmanuel Macron quels sont
les grandes lignes un constat pour
commencer le système actuel de santé est
à bout de souffle c'est un diagnostic
qui est partagé par pratiquement par
tout le monde et même par Emmanuel
Macron qui l'a rappelé lors de son
déplacement vendredi dernier dans un
centre hospitalier de Corbeil-Essonnes
pour le chef de l'État l'une des causes
des défaillances du système c'est
notamment la réforme du temps de travail
écoutez-le qu'est-ce qui marche pas dans
notre hôpital aujourd'hui c'est que je
le disais ce qui est vrai c'est le
dernier endroit où juridiquement les 35
heures fonctionnent encore c'est une
hyper rigidité comment remettre debout
notre système de santé Emmanuel Macron a
annoncé une série de mesures par miel
une réforme du financement de l'hôpital
cela passerait par la fin de la
tarification à l'activité c'est-à-dire
la fin de l'idée que l'hôpital doit être
une entreprise rentable comme une autre
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui le
financement des hôpitaux des pans en
grande partie du nombre d'actes médicaux
effectués par les établissements je vois
que vous
hochez de la tête à la vision on va
parler dans un instant autre mesure
annoncée par Emmanuel Macron une
nouvelle organisation du temps de
travail à l'hôpital cette réorganisation
devra intervenir d'ici au premier juin
et pour cela le chef de l'État a
notamment promis une revalorisation des
gares et du travail de nuit le chef de
l'État aussi annoncé le recrutement de
6000 assistants médicaux pour la
médecine de ville l'objectif c'est
d'alléger un peu le travail
administratif des médecins pour qu'il
puisse consacrer un peu plus de temps à
leur patient Oriane et ces annonces
elles n'ont pas calmé le monde de la
santé non la mobilisation continue pour
les médecins généralistes les
laboratoires et les hôpitaux publics la
grève de la permanence des soins se
poursuit les médecins généralistes par
exemple réclam toujours l'augmentation
du prix de la consultation de 25 à 50
euros à cela le gouvernement dit niet
Emmanuel Macron propose seulement un
coup de pouce pour ceux qui
en plus de passion alors est-ce que ça
va nous permettre de trouver plus
facilement un médecin généraliste pas
certain Emmanuel Macron c'est en tout
cas engagé auprès de ceux qui souffrent
de maladies chroniques écoutez-le et 600
000 patients avec une maladie chronique
se verront proposer un médecin traitant
avant la fin de l'année ou plus
exactement je veux que ces patients
chroniques et accès à ce que
j'appellerai une équipe traitant ah non
mais non il y aura donc un débat cet
après-midi si au Sénat vous en faisant
attendez quelque chose
on est au Parlement le Parlement doit
parlementer maintenant
organiser un débat pour discuter et sans
qu'il y ait au bout de conclusion ou
sans qu'il y ait au bout de décision
pour moi je pense que ce n'est pas
extrêmement nécessaire il y aura
évidemment question du Plan Santé
d'Emmanuel Macron qu'elle regarde vous
portez de manière générale sur ce plan
annoncé par le chef de l'État la semaine
dernière
dans votre intervention particulier vous
n'êtes pas vous avez parlé la T2 la
tarification à l'activité la réforme du
financement de l'hôpital la réforme de
la T2A date de 2002 elle a été mise en
place parce que avant les hôpitaux
marchaient sur des budgets globaux et
donc le budget ne changeait pas d'une
année sur l'autre quel que soit
l'activité de l'hôpital je vais pas
rentrer dans le détail ça veut dire
qu'il y avait des hôpitaux qui vivaient
grassement sans activité et donc il y
avait une activité énorme et qui avait
pas d'argent pour le faire donc la
tarification de l'activité a été mise en
place pour ça ça a eu un effet
inflationniste c'est vrai au niveau
d'activité des hôpitaux mais maintenant
dire que c'est l'essentiel du
financement des hôpitaux ce n'est pas
vrai puisque la T2A l'intervient qu'à
hauteur de 52% des budgets globaux des
hôpitaux donc il y a 48% des budgets qui
viennent d'autres ressources que la
tarification de l'activité alors qu'on
veut changer ça et vous n'êtes pas
tellement d'accord avec cette
proposition il y a une marge
le discours du président de la
République et ce qui a été ce qui a été
écrit dans son discours et ce qui va se
faire réellement de ce que j'entends par
la suite il devrait y avoir une part
dans les budgets des hôpitaux tes 2A une
part budget global et une part
dite territoire populationnel
c'est-à-dire donc en fonction des
populations et des territoires les
hôpitaux devraient avoir des notations
différentes en fonction de l'activité
sur ces populations en particulier donc
il y a trois
sources de réflexion possible sur le
financement des hôpitaux mais ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure en aparté et
que je vais redire ici ça n'est pas la
T2A qui qui doit être remise en cause
dans le budget global de la santé
c'est
l'objectif national de dépenses
d'assurance maladie c'est long dame
la France au niveau de l'assurance
maladie dépense à peu près pour 2023
disons 250 milliards donc ce qui est pas
une petite somme quand même ce qu'il
faudrait c'est que chaque année on met
un objectif de dépenses c'est-à-dire une
augmentation du des dépenses de la
science maladie qui soit entre 3 et 4%.
donc plus de moyens donc plus de moyens
pour le système plus de moyens financier
parce que tout simplement les techniques
évoluent les maladies sont différentes
et donc c'est salaires l'évolution des
salaires des personnels médicaux et là
aussi donc il faut et puis aussi les
investissements immobiliers qui ont été
oubliés pendant plusieurs années et
depuis la crise de 2008 les ondes sont
du temps de Monsieur Sarkozy aux
alentours de 2,8 au lieu de 4 du temps
de Monsieur Holland nous allons autour
de 1,7 au lieu de 4 et depuis monsieur
Macron aux alentours de 2 4 au lieu de 4
donc le plan d'Emmanuel Macron n'est pas
assez ambitieux si je résume
est à 6 non Damme est à 2,4 pour les
hôpitaux il est à 6 en moyenne parce
qu'il y a eu le Ségur à côté je rappelle
que le Ségur ça n'est qu'un rattraperge
des salaires qui avaient été bloqué
pendant l'ambition il y a de toute façon
ça manque d'ambition un manque d'analyse
après il faut trouver l'argent
c'est facile pour moi de dire on met un
truc à 3% un Honda à 3% mais si on mène
en damas 3%, mais faut trouver 6
milliards de plus sous les ans 6
milliards ça se trouve pas comme ça sous
le cerveau d'un cheval il y a aussi on
en a beaucoup parlé cette colère cette
grève de certains médecins libéraux qui
jugé irresponsable par le ministre de la
Santé par vous aussi
je
prouve pas je pense pas qu'elle soit
irresponsable puisque s'il y a grève il
y a pas obligatoirement fermeture des
des cabinets médicaux et les soins sont
quand même assurés je je pense que ce
qui est
pas acceptable c'est la demande
d'augmentation du coût du prix des
cotisateurs des consultations de 25 à 50
euros je pense que c'est beaucoup et ça
ne devrait pas entraîner pour autant une
augmentation du nombre de consultations
par jour et donc il y aura toujours des
patients qui ne trouveront pas de
médecin donc je ne pense pas je ne
je comprends qu'il puisse le faire mais
je ne la trouve pas sur puisqu'on a
connu on est encore dedans une triple
épidémie à la fois bronchiolite covid et
la grippe qui en plus est
particulièrement virulent de cette année
est-ce que le gouvernement a pris les
bonnes mesures est-ce qu'il aurait dû
imposer le port du masque
depuis octobre depuis même septembre au
moins imposer le port du masque dans le
lieu public et imposer le port du masque
dans les transports serait probablement
éviter une propagation de la grippe et
da covid en particulier et peut-être
bien aussi des bronchiolites donc un
manque de courage politique
probablement je sais pas je suis pas
d'accord
on en trouve partout on n'est pas obligé
d'attendre une obligation
gouvernementale pour en mettre il y a
aussi un manque de responsabilités
de la propagation des virus pourtant
depuis la covid on a beaucoup parlé il y
a un manque de prise en conscience de du
danger de ces épidémies et contrairement
à certains pays asiatiques où le masque
en hiver est mis en place etc et donc
je crois que il faut mettre en place
chaque année en période hivernale dans
les lieux publics et dans les transports
l'obligation du masque et puis chaque
année chaque année systématiquement on
voit bien que les épidémies arrivent
tous les ans la grippe arrive tous les
ans les bronchi arrivent tous les ans et
qu'il faudrait une obligation
législative pourquoi pas je veux dire au
moins au départ pendant les 7 8
premières années après sera prise mais
au moins au départ parce que
d'abord ça met en tension l'ensemble du
système de santé dans notre pays ensuite
ça entraîne quand même une diminution
d'activité économique qu'on le veuille
ou non et puis ça entraîne des morts qui
n'aurait pas dû être mort s'ils avaient
pu éviter l'épidémie merci
tout à l'heure ce sera dans le club et
on suivra le débat santé cet après-midi
dans l'hémicycle on va aller chez vous
direction Avignon retrouver Guillaume
ballet bonjour Guillaume merci d'être
avec nous journaliste à Vaucluse Matin
et on va parler d'un autre sujet parce
que vous revenez dans le journal sur
votre rencontre avec la préfète de
Vaucluse qui vous a présenté ses
priorités
bonjour à tous oui effectivement
Violaine Desmarais nous a accordé un
entretenu en ce début d'année dans
lequel elle revient sur sur ses
priorités pour le Vaucluse avec en ligne
de mire la protection de l'environnement
mais surtout la sécurité alors rien
d'étonnant finalement quand on sait que
ces dernières semaines notre département
a été émaillé très régulièrement par des
règlements de comptes liés au trafic de
stupéfiants je pense notamment au double
meurtre de début décembre dans un
quartier d'Avignon deux jeunes hommes de
18 et 22 ans avait perdu la vie et puis
il y a cette terrible soirée de Noël ou
un individu a ouvert le feu à la
kalachnikov sur deux femmes et un homme
aborde un véhicule dans une artère
passante de la ville par miracle il n'y
a pas eu de mort mais les habitants ont
été particulièrement choqués par la
ferme
dans ces conditions violets de démarrer
en temps mettre davantage de pression
sur les dealers en multipliant les
opérations spéciales notamment mais la
préfecture de Vaucluse veut aussi mettre
davantage de pression sur les
consommateurs je cite s'il n'y a plus de
consommation si on tarie la consommation
il n'y a plus de trafic de stupéfiant
l'objectif est donc de multiplier les
contrôles routiers de généraliser la
vente forfaitaire en d'autres termes
finis les garde à vue pour les
consommateurs la Violaine des marais
préfère sans prendre directement à leur
porte-monnaie selon ses dires alors
d'après vous monsieur Milan est-ce que
ces mesures de répression peuvent avoir
un effet concret sur le trafic de drogue
dans le Vaucluse
bonjour d'abord et merci pour la
question je voudrais juste ajouter une
chose avant de vous répondre c'est que
finalement
la nomination de Madame des marais c'est
une surprise et je pense qu'elle fait un
travail assez remarquable sur le
département de Vaucluse bien qu'elle
soit arrivée depuis très peu de temps ce
ensuite bien évidemment madame Desmarais
utilise
l'ensemble de l'arsenal législatif qui
est à sa disposition
et donc elle fait de la répression parce
que elle peut pas faire autre chose pour
l'instant dans le cadre de l'arsenal
législatif après tout elle est préfet et
elle doit appliquer faire appliquer la
loi
cela dit
toucher directement au portefeuille des
consommateurs pourquoi pas moi je
préférerais aussi quand même temps on
touche au portefeuille des dealers et là
je pense que ça marcherait nettement
mieux que de les mettre prison parce que
quand ils sont en prison ils continuent
et puis quand ils sortent de prison ils
reprennent le boulot par contre si on
leur prenait leur argent les voitures
qu'ils ont etc je pense que ça les
ferait peut-être un peu plus réfléchir
donc oui pour la répression quoique on
pourrait réfléchir à d'autres systèmes
législatifs mais c'est peut-être pas le
moment étant donné qu'elle est retraite
qui a la santé qui a la guerre en
Ukraine etc mais oui aussi pour une
répression sur le portefeuille de ceux
qui vivent de ça
et Guillaume on va parler du Festival
d'Avignon du célèbre festival d'Avignon
puisque il y avait une menace sur son
organisation en 2024 à cause des Jeux
Olympiques on en est où
alors on en est où ah ben écoutez c'est
la bonne nouvelle de ce début de semaine
le gouvernement a confirmé lundi que
l'édition 2024 du Festival d'Avignon
serait maintenu elle sera simplement
avancée de quelques jours et devrait
commencer le 29 juin pour se clôturer
autour du pour ce clôturer le 21 juillet
alors attention toutefois parce que la
préfète de Vaucluse nous a indiqué que
cette date d'ouverture pouvait
possiblement évoluer on sait que les
ministères de la Culture des Sports de
l'intérieur se sont mis d'accord pour
que l'événement ait lieu malgré les Jeux
olympiques de Paris mais la question de
l'école elle elle reste entière en 2024
la période scolaire de rester tendre
jusqu'au 5 juillet au soir or on sait
que généralement le Festival d'Avignon
prend ses quartiers dans les écoles et
gymnase de la ville une réflexion est
donc en cours pour déterminer ce qui les
écoliers doivent partir plus tôt en
vacances ou si l'ouverture du festival
doit être reportée au 1er juillet vous
l'aurez compris finalement il faudra
encore attendre quelques semaines voire
quelques mois avant de connaître avec
certitude les dat de cette édition 2024
du Festival d'Avignon alors justement
vous monsieur Emilion Milon étiez vous
inquiet d'une possible annulation de
cette édition non
parce que c'est clair non non parce que
je le Festival d'Avignon c'est un
festival international c'est l'image
mondiale d'Avignon et
toucher à l'image mondiale d'Avignon
comme ça je ne pense pas que le ministre
aurait eu l'audace de le faire ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième point
vous habitez à Avignon comme moi vous
savez que début juillet il fait une
chaleur torride et que les quatre ou
cinq premiers jours de juillet les
enfants de bossent plus à l'école donc
il doit y avoir des solutions à trouver
assez rapidement
merci beaucoup Alain Milou merci
Guillaume vallée d'avoir été avec nous
on regarde évidemment la une de vos
cuisses matin c'était Elisabeth borne ce
qui vous attend les points clés de la
réforme des retraites c'est évidemment à
lire ce matin dans vos Cluses matin
merci beaucoup Guillaume vallée d'avoir
été avec nous merci Alain Milon d'avoir
été notre invité pendant cette première
demi-heure on va parler évidemment de la
réforme des retraites dans 20 minutes
dans le club puisqu'elle a été présentée
hier par Elisabeth band opposé au report
de l'âge de départ à 64 ans les
syndicats ont d'ores et déjà annoncé une
mobilisation le 19 janvier on reviendra
là dessus et on va continuer en parler
avec notre prochain invité c'est
terrible verte merci